For floating point, each color channel is defined as values from 0 to 1. 0, 0, 0
is black, 1, 1, 1 is white. Setting just the red channel gives red, green to
green and blue to blue. Where things go off the tracks for some people is when
we set a color as follows, RGB of 1, 1 and 0. This is to make a color using the
red and green channels at their maximum and with no blue. If I take red paint
and green paint and mix them together, I get at best a murky brown. This happens
because paint colors are formed by absorption of various wave lengths of light.
The color model for mixing paints and inks is called subtractive color. The
three primary colors used in printing are cyan Magenta and yellow, with black
added as its own dark ink. This printing system is called CMYK with K standing
for key and essentially meaning black. As different colors are mixed, the
pigments become darker over all. In computer graphics a monitor, such as this
one, emits light of different labelings. Our eyes see light in wavelengths
between 390 and 750 manometers. Longer wavelength light is red, shorter is blue
with the rainbow in between. If we specify some red and some green light then
these contributions are added together giving a brighter color overall. This
color model is called additive color. See the additional course material for
more articles about this area. If you want a particular color, the additive
color RGB values are what you will need to determine. To get familiar with this
way of mixing colors try out the demo that follows.